[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend Christian otto hat später
alles Wichtige vom Sport und wieder
große Freude bei der Biathlon-WM guten
Abend dann schauen wir gemeinsam auf die
Themen heute mit einem politfokus auf
Berlin
die CDU gewinnt die Wahl in Berlin
deutlich SPD Grüne und Linke verlieren
stimmen könnten aber weiter regieren die
Wiederholungswahl läuft offenbar
weitgehend frei
nur noch vereinzelte Rettungen im
Erdbebengebiet schon jetzt mehr als
30.000 tote viele Verhaftungen wegen
Fusch am Bau
und Silber nach Gold Denise hermannweg
holt bei der Biathlon WM in Oberhof ihre
zweite WM-Medaille
ja ein historischer Tag heute in Berlin
nach der pannenwahl im September 21
wählten die Hauptstädter zum zweiten Mal
innerhalb von anderthalb Jahren die CDU
klare Wahl Gewinnerin ob sie aber den
Regierungsauftrag erhält das ist noch
ungewiss zwar hat die SPD also die
Partei der Regierende Bürgermeisterin
Giffey klar verloren aber sie könnte das
Bündnis mit den Grünen und Linken
fortsetzen gehen wir live ins ZDF
Wahlstudio nach Berlin zu Matthias
vornhof guten Abend Matthias wie sieht
denn die allerneuste Hochrechnung aus
genau das schauen wir uns jetzt an
Hochrechnungen 19 Uhr demnach kommt die
SPD hier in Berlin auf 18 % und hat
Verluste die CDU kommt auf 28% und
gewinnt 10 Punkte dazu im Vergleich zu
2021 zu der annullierten Wahl die Grünen
18,2 mit leichten Verlusten die Linke
12,7 ebenfalls Verluste die AFD 9 Vier
gewinnt etwas dazu und die FDP liegt bei
fünf Prozent wo nicht klar ist ob sie es
schafft ins Abgeordnetenhaus oder nicht
und jetzt gucken wir mal auf die
Koalitionsmöglichkeiten wer kann da mit
wem regieren und da sehen wir bei 66
hier diese senkrechte Linie das ist das
Minimum ansetzen dass man braucht für
die Mehrheit SPD grün und Linke haben
das deutlich egal ob grüne oder SPD
zweitstärkste Kraft werden CDU und SPD
kommen genau auf diese 66 die ist
bräuchte und CDU und Grüne ganz genau so
ein letzter Blick kurz auf die
Wahlbeteiligung da sehen wir ganz rechts
65 % sind es heute
75,4 waren es vor anderthalb Jahren da
war parallel Bundestagswahl und 2016
66,9 also heute noch mal ein bisschen
schwächer Matthias das sind wirklich
sehr interessante Zahlen wen wünschen
sich die Berlinerinnen und Berliner denn
am liebsten im Roten Rathaus ja das ist
eine gute Frage das haben wir auch
gefragt das Ergebnis das sehen wir hier
der Senat aus SPD Grünen und Linke macht
seine gut sagen 34 Prozent schlecht
sagen 57 Prozent sehr schlechtes Zeugnis
wenn man dann aber fragt die CDU an der
Regierung würde es besser machen sagen
das auch nur 29 Prozent und 40 Prozent
sagen kein Unterschied also großes
Skepsis gegenüber allen Konstellation
was nichts daran ändert dass die CDU
diese Wahl gewonnen hat heute Abend dann
vielen Dank Matthias vornhoff ja es wird
also mit Sicherheit noch ein langer
Abend an dem diese Zahl noch intensiv
diskutiert und interpretiert werden
dürften und so auch jetzt mit Bettina
Schausten und den wichtigsten
Spitzenkandidatinnen und Kandidaten und
wir sagen guten Abend Bettina zwei
Studio ja so ist es metri hallo aus
Berlin und wir beginnen traditionell mit
dem Amtsinhaber in diesem Fall mit der
regierenden Bürgermeisterin Franziska
gefallen ein bitterer Abend das haben
sie uns schon gesagt in der Hochrechnung
19 Uhr liegen sie jetzt tatsächlich auch
auf Rang drei knapp hinter den Grünen
können Sie daraus einen
regierungsanspruch noch ableiten also
zunächst einmal ist es ganz klar es ist
ein bitterer Abend für die SPD wir haben
hier eine Situation der die Berliner und
Berliner ganz klar gezeigt haben dass
sie sich Dinge anders wünschen und es
wird jetzt darauf ankommen wie der Abend
sich noch entwickelt wir müssen abwarten
natürlich sind wir angetreten um eine
Regierung anzuführen dafür müsste es um
ein anderes Bundes einzugehen mindestens
Platz zwei werden und das müssen wir
abwarten ob das gelingt sie legen sich
da noch nicht fest der Wahlsieger des
heutigen Abends ist ka Wegner von der
CDU erstmal seit
1999 geht die CDU hier wieder als
stärkste Kraft aus der Wahl hervor war
aber was ist dieser Sieg nun wert wie
werden sie versuchen
SPD und Grüne zum mitregieren zu bewegen
ich glaube das Wahlergebnis zeigt
eindeutig dass die Berlinerinnen und
Berliner den Wechsel wollten dass die
Berlinerinnen und Berliner den Wechsel
auch gewählt haben und die CDU jetzt
einen klaren Auftrag zur Bildung einer
Regierung hat und wir sollten jetzt
dieses Wahlergebnis auch mit Respekt zur
Kenntnis nehmen und in Gespräche
eintreten und ich werde sowohl SPD als
auch grüne zu Gesprächen einladen und
dann schauen wir mal im Moment sieht es
tatsächlich so aus dass es auch für ein
Zweier Bündnis reichen könnte Bettina
jarasch ist die Spitzenkandidatin der
Grünen und wird entscheiden müssen ob
sie am Ende auch Gespräche führt zur
Bildung einer z.B schwarz grün Regierung
sind Sie bereit
zunächst mal möchte ich der CDU zu
diesem Wahlergebnis gratulieren und dann
muss ich einmal kurz sagen ich freue
mich sehr über unsere Ergebnis denn es
war ein harter Wahlkampf es war auch ein
hart geführter Wahlkampf und wir sind
mit der klaren veränderungsbotschaft
angetreten in einer Zeit von vielen
Krisen wo viele Menschen auch Angst vor
Veränderungen haben deswegen freut es
mich sehr dass wir so viele Menschen von
uns überzeugen konnten wie der Abend
tatsächlich ausgeht werden wir sehen
wir werden natürlich
gesprächseinladungen annehmen und mit
demokratischen Parteien reden sowieso
wir haben aber auch von Anfang an und
zwar sehr klar gesagt dass wir eine
Präferenz haben wir würden gerne die
Koalition mit der SPD und den linken
fortführen am liebsten untergrüner
Führung ob das möglich ist wird der
Abend jetzt erst noch zeigen aber das
war immer unsere Präferenz wir denken
dass wir insgesamt gut
zusammengearbeitet haben und zu dieser
Stadt passen das war die Präferenz und
bleibt es zunächst ja Berlin wir sehen
es muss Antworten finden wo man Lesko
war und Markus groß schauen jetzt noch
mal auf Stimmungen und weitere Stimmen
an diesem Wahlabend
großer Jubel bei der Berliner Linken als
die ersten Prognose Zahlen kommen trotz
möglicher Verluste ein Ergebnis mit dem
auch der Spitzenkandidat zufrieden ist
also wenn es das Ergebnis ist dann fällt
mir ein Stein vom Herzen weil wir sind
ja nicht erfolgsverwöhnt als Linke in
den vergangenen Monaten gewesen und wir
haben hier in Berlin in einem
dreier-rennen zwischen CDU SPD und
Grünen und zweite Rathaus auch nicht
ganz einfach gehabt auch in dieser
Materialschlacht durchzudringen Applaus
auch bei der AFD die Rechtspopulisten
gewinnen bei der Wiederholungswahl wohl
dazu obwohl das Ziel ein zweistelliges
Ergebnis nach den ersten Zahlen
womöglich nicht ganz erreicht wird
wir haben ein großartiges Wahlergebnis
für Berliner Verhältnisse eingefahren
wir haben unsere WLAN mobilisieren
können wir haben uns verbessert das ist
das entscheidende und darauf bin ich
auch sehr stolz bei der FDP die
Gesichter angespannt es könnte eng
werden heute abend unklar derzeit ob die
Liberalen die 5% Hürde nehmen werden das
ist jetzt ein langer Abend natürlich ist
man als Wahlkämpfer an so einem Abend
dann auch schon mal erleichtert da wenn
es stabiler ist die Prognose ist im
Augenblick bei fünf insoweit heißt es
jetzt in den nächsten Stunden noch
abwarten die Wahlwiederholung stand nach
den Pannen besonders im Fokus der
Europa-Rat schickte Beobachter nach
einer ersten Einschätzung des
Landeswahlleiters gab es bislang keine
größeren Probleme allerdings könnte die
Wahlbeteiligung niedriger sein als beim
letzten Mal ein zweiter ohne Gang bin in
anderthalb Jahren die Reaktionen der
Stimmberechtigten unterschiedlich
ist ja keine Frage und zweimal los reden
muss
natürlich was was viel Kosten verursacht
und auch einige Energie ich finde
Wellness halt irgendwie auch
Bürgerpflicht und in dem Fall muss man
die pflichtheitenzeit des mal erledigen
ihr haben die meisten Berlinerinnen und
Berliner ihre Stimme gegeben bei der CDU
dürfte heute Abend besonders ausgelassen
gefeiert werden
[Applaus]
ja so ist es natürlich hier zurück im
Wahlstudio der klare Wahlgewinner ist
Kai Wegner von der CDU aber er hat eben
noch keine
Regierungsmehrheit zusammen die auf der
linken Seite durchaus vorhanden ist
jetzt hört man aus ihrer Partei Herr
Wegner da drohe wahlklau schließen sie
sich solchen Befürchtungen solchen
Vorwürfen an das war gar nicht aus
unserer Partei sondern das wurde auch in
den Medien gespielt aber wissen Sie für
mich ist das alles entscheidende dass
der Wahlkampf jetzt mal vorbei ist und
jetzt gibt's eine Verantwortung wir
haben ein Wahlergebnis und es geht darum
eine stabile Regierung für diese Stadt
aufzustellen die die Probleme dieser
Stadt anpackt und da geht's mir
tatsächlich meine stabile Regierung um
eine Regierung die wirklich
zusammenarbeitet im Interesse der
Berlinerinnen und Berliner und dafür
führen wir jetzt diese Gespräche die
Stadt ist gespalten und das müssen wir
jetzt endlich mal aufheben und diese
Stadt wieder zusammenführen jetzt die
Frage Frau Giffey Juniorpartner in einer
großen Koalition ist das für sie denkbar
persönlich also ich habe von Anfang an
gesagt wir machen
kein koalitionsverkauf sondern wir
warten das Wahlergebnis ab wir haben
jetzt ein Wahlergebnis und es gehört
dazu dass wir Gespräche führen aber ich
sage es auch an dieser Stelle wenn es
die Möglichkeit gibt für ein Bündnis und
der Führung der SPD dann wird das unsere
Präferenz sein und alles weitere müssen
wir abwarten das hängt jetzt von den
Ergebnissen das abends ab und auch davon
wie wir in weitere Gespräche dann auch
gehen selbstverständlich stehen wir für
Gespräche zur Verfügung soweit der stand
am heutigen Abend ein spannender
Wahlabend und damit jetzt von Berlin
zunächst mal wieder zurück in die
heute-Sendung nach Mainz danke Bettina
ins Berliner Wahlstudio also ein
besonderer Urnengang in Berlin ist da
heute zu Ende gegangen nötig geworden
sie wissen es war ja diese
Wiederholungswahl weil im September 21
Stimmzettel fehlten Wahllokale
vorübergehend geschlossen waren und in
vielen Fällen auch noch nach 18 Uhr
gewählt wurde heute sollte alles heute
sollte vieles besser laufen wir gehen
dazu zu Stefan Merse Burger nach Berlin
Stefan sicher wurde heute ganz genau
hingeschaut wie lief's denn in den über
2000 Wahllokalen
du hast rechtmetrie es wurde ganz genau
hingeschaut wir haben auch hingeschaut
ganz genau unsere Teams haben nichts
weiter bemerkt der Landeswahlleiter
Stefan brüchler ist sehr zufrieden es
hat wenn überhaupt dann nur kleinere
Pannen gegeben also mit all das Geld was
in die Hand genommen wurde für mehr
Kabinen mehr ohne mehr Wahlhelfer das
hat sich ausgezeichnet die Wahlhelfer
haben ein sogenanntes Erfrischungsgeld
bekommen das kriegen sie für ihren
Einsatz hier früher waren das 60 heute
240 €, also Berlin macht keine
schlechten Schlagzeilen und auch die
internationalen Beobachter vom Europarat
die sind zufrieden abschließende
Ergebnisse gibt es morgen um 11 Uhr dazu
wie die Wahl verlaufen ist aber ich
glaube man kann schon heute sagen Berlin
kann Wahlen kann wieder Wahlen und damit
steht im Zentrum zum Glück das Ergebnis
und mögliche Regierungsbildung und nicht
ein schreckliches Chaos danke nach
Berlin Stefan Merseburger ja und je
nachdem wie es für die Parteien ausgeht
bzw ausgegangen ist kann so eine
landeswahl immer auch Rückenwind oder
unter das Gegenteil für die
Bundesparteien produzieren wir haben die
wichtigsten Stimmen und Reaktionen
zusammengefasst dieses Wahlergebnis
zeigt doch dass die Berliner ein Wechsel
wollen also entweder interpretiere ich
die Zahlen falsch aber das was ich den
ganzen Abend höre man will einen Wechsel
man will kein weiter so da empfehle ich
alle demokratischen Parteien dieses
wahrzunehmen und anzunehmen und
miteinander zu reden und der in
Regierungsauftrag hat die CDU das ist
offenkundig was das Ergebnis jetzt schon
zeigt ist das eine Regierungskoalition
unter Franziska Giffey und der SPD mit
Beteiligung der SPD möglich ist die
Koalition die für den Zusammenhalt in
der weltoffenen Stadt steht die in
Lösungen denkt statt den Problemen die
Berliner als Weltstadt präsentiert und
voranbringt wir freuen uns dass wir ein
starkes Ergebnis haben es sieht so aus
als könnten wir es bisher beste von der
letzten Wahl vielleicht stabilisieren
und wir sehen das als Auftrag was
bezahlbares Wohnen was Klimaschutz in
Berlin angeht und werden in diese
Richtung natürlich
in den nächsten Tagen Gesprache mit den
demokratischen Parteien führen das
Ergebnis zeigt die LINKE wird gebraut
die Linken Themen sind da es geht um
bezahlbaren Wohnraum und soziale
Gerechtigkeit und Klimaschutz und
deshalb können wir heute Abend feiern
und sagen das ist ein richtig gutes
Ergebnis für die Linke in einer doch
recht schwierigen Zeit wir haben jetzt
bei dieser Wahl die natürlich auch einen
kurzen intensiven Wahlkampf beinhaltet
hat mit Christian Brinker als Spitzen
kann ihn zugelegt das ist erstmal sehr
positiv warten wir mal den weiteren
Abend ab insgesamt muss man sagen dass
wir natürlich mit unserer Politik hier
in Berlin auch schwierige Verhältnisse
haben hier ist es Brennglas der Republik
und wir werden hier natürlich
konstruktive
Oppositionsarbeit machen Berlin ist ja
das kann man ja mit Händen greifen
wirklich eine Wechselstimmung da gewesen
die Verkehrspolitik wenn Sie daran
denken oder die Tatsache dass die
Verwaltung nicht funktioniert für der
Senats schon verantwortlich ist dieser
rot grüne Senat deswegen sind wir
gespannt ob der wächst am Ende gelingt
und dafür braucht es natürlich auch eine
FDP im Abgeordnetenhaus insofern bin ich
optimistisch
ja interessante Ausgangslage die immer
aktuellste Hochrechnung die können Sie
jederzeit online sehen in unserer ZDF
heute App und nach dieser Sendung alle
weiteren Entwicklungen dann auch in
Berlin MZF Wahlstudio nach den massiven
Erdbeben in der Türkei und Syrien gibt
es kaum noch Hoffnung Überlebende unter
den Trümmern zu finden jeden Tag steigt
die Zahl der Opfer mittlerweile sind
insgesamt deutlich mehr als 30.000 Tote
und über 85.000 verletzte bestätigt
trotzdem konnten auch heute noch
Menschen lebend geborgen werden den
Überlebenden im Krisengebiet fehlt es am
aller nötigsten Jörg Brase beginnt
seinen Bericht in der türkischen Provinz
Hatay
Essensausgabe in einem der vielen
Zeltlager in Hatay es gibt etwas Warmes
immerhin sie haben ein Zelt darüber dem
Kopf zumindest das doch es gebe hier
keine Toiletten es stinke sie könnten
nicht schlafen beschwert sich Familie
kavasolu drei Tage hätten sie auf Hilfe
warten müssen
ich habe vier Mitglieder meiner Familie
verloren nur drei meiner Geschwister
haben überlebt
bitte holt uns hier raus wir stecken
hier fest und haben niemanden der uns
helfen kann
Verzweiflung bei den einen Erleichterung
bei denen die immer noch Überlebende aus
den Trümmern holen nach unglaublichen
150 Stunden wird dieses fünfjährige
Mädchen gebauten
unterdessen gibt es erste Festnahmen im
Zusammenhang mit vermuteten Baumängeln
am Istanbuler Flughafen wird ein
Bauunternehmer festgenommen der sich
offenbar absetzen wollte
wir haben die Büros für Erdbeben
Kriminalität eingerichtet alle
oberstaatsanwälte in den zehn
betroffenen Provinzen arbeiten auf
Hochtouren und sie haben bereits mit
ihren Ermittlungen begonnen
während in der Türkei schon nach
Schuldigen gesucht wird warten Menschen
in Syrien weiter auf Hilfe ein Konvoi
des kurdischen Roten Halbmonds wollte
Hilfsgüter nach Aleppo bringen wurde
aber von der syrischen Regierung
gestoppt
wir bekommen keine Genehmigung weiter zu
fahren in das Gebiet um dort Hilfe zu
leisten es sei denn wir gehen mindestens
die Hälfte unserer gesamten Hilfsgüter
ab von den Vereinten Nationen hieß es
heute man habe die Menschen in Syrien
bisher im Stich gelassen eine Erkenntnis
die für viele hier zu spät kommt
wir sind jetzt mit einer Brühl im
türkischen Adana verbunden Anne die am
stärksten von den Erdbeben Betroffene
türkische Provinz ist eben hat er haben
wir gerade gesehen du warst dort in der
Hafenstadt Iskenderun was hast Du erlebt
ja vor dem Beben hat er es können uns
250.000 Einwohner was wir heute gesehen
haben war eine in weiten Teilen
zerstörte Stadt viele eingestürzte
Häuser über der Stadt hängt
Leichengeruch eine riesige Staubwolke
weil viele Rettungsteams mittlerweile
dabei sind mit schweren Gerät große
Trümmerteile zu bewegen trotzdem warten
noch immer Angehörige vor den Häusern
warten auf Gewissheit sie sind am Ende
ihrer Kräfte durch die Stadt ihren
Überlebende so muss man das wirklich
sagen auf der Suche nach Kleidung nach
Essen und ja es gibt diese Hilfe auch
das haben wir gesehen viele türkische
freiwillige dass er spanische Militär
ist vor Ort spanische Marine Soldaten
aber diese Hilfe läuft insgesamt
schleppend der türkische
Katastrophenschutz hat Zelte errichtet
aber da reicht die Kapazität bei weitem
nicht aus es kennen darum braucht
dringend mehr Hilfe
vielen Dank für deine Schilderung nach
Iskenderun eine Brühl also die Menschen
brauchen Hilfe und wenn sie unterstützen
möchten dann können Sie das tun beim
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe hier
sind die Daten IBAN
de6500 400-00
400 600 Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben Türkei
Syrien alle Informationen auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder auf der ZDF
Textseite 89.0 oder sie scannen den
QR-Code
Rätselraten über ein weiteres
unbekanntes Flugobjekt am Himmel über
Nordamerika nach einem Abschluss
vorgestern über Alaska hat die Armee
jetzt über Kanada ein verdächtiges
Objekt vom Himmel geholt erst Anfang
Februar zerstörte die US Armee einen
mutmaßlichen spionageballon aus China er
soll nach US-Angaben Militäranlagen in
Nordamerika ausspioniert haben China
behauptet es handelt sich nur um einen
Wetterballon
Touchdown Field Goal wem bei diesem
Worten die Augen leuchten der schaut
sicher heute Nacht den Super Bowl die 57
us-footballmeisterschaft diesmal in
Arizona es ist der sportliche sportliche
Höhepunkt der Saison und eine riesige
Show mit viel Commerz einen Comeback von
popstar Rihanna und dem Wunsch vieler
Fans die gesellschaftliche Spaltung kurz
zu vergessen Benjamin Daniel
Party in Phoenix schon lange vor dem
Kick-off ob Chiefs oder Eagles Fan
Republikaner oder Demokrat Amerikas mega
Sport-Event lässt zumindest kurzfristig
eine zerstrittene Nation ein Stück
zusammenrücken
ohne den Sport sind wir gespalten und
leben in unserer eigenen kleinen Welt
genau bete das hier bringt uns zusammen
es lässt uns all den Quatsch der uns
trennt vergessen
hier sind wir alle eins
starkwater back Patrick mahomes tritt
mit seinen Kansas City Chiefs zum
dritten Mal in vier Jahren beim
Superbowl an und wird natürlich alles
geben um die Philadelphia Eagles um
ihren Quarterback jayline hurts zu
schlagen zum ersten Mal treten zwei
schwarze Quarterbacks in der
stadtformation gegeneinander an außerdem
stehen sich auch erstmals zwei Brüder
gegenüber
ein 30 Sekunden Werbespot kostet 7
Millionen Dollar neuer Rekord kein
Wunder bei schätzungsweise 200 Millionen
Zuschauern weltweit knapp 70.000 werden
vor Ort im State Farm Stadium dabei sein
wer jetzt noch ein Ticket ergattern will
der muss mindestens 5000 Dollar dafür
zahlen wir haben Leute getroffen die
haben ihr Auto verkauft um heute Abend
live im Stadion dabei sein zu können das
zeigt welche Bedeutung diese Spiel für
Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner hat und
natürlich auch für Fans auf der ganzen
Welt und so läuft er langsam dem Ende
entgegen der Countdown zum größten
einzelsport-event der Welt dem Super
Bowl Nummer 57
ich glaube ein Auto muss man für den
Wintersport nicht verkaufen wenn man z.B
die Biathlon WM sehen will es gibt die
zweite Medaille für Deutschland mal also
von Hochgenuss und total im Glück
spricht eine glückliche zufriedene
Dennis Hermann Wick zwei Tage nachdem WM
Gold im Sprint er kämpft sie in Oberhof
Silber in der Verfolgung in der Loipe
erneut top beim Schießen diesmal nicht
ganz souverän
wie so häufig auch heute der Showdown
beim letzten Schießen Denise Herrmann
Wick auf Bahn eins daneben die Französin
Julia Simon Hermann victac nerven muss
zweimal in die Strafrunde die Französin
im Vorteil nur ein Fehler hinten mit 0
das ist schon noch mal das wäre schon
noch mal gewesen aber es war halt nicht
so einfach und weiß natürlich auch ein
bisschen belastet nach drei Wettkämpfen
nun also die zweite Medaille für die
führende im Gesamtweltcup Julia Simon
aus Frankreich Denis hermannweg freut
sich nach Sprint Gold über Verfolgung
Silber und die norwegeren Martha als
büroland komplettiert das Podest gewinnt
Bronze beim überragenden
verfolgungssiegt es Norwegers Johannes
Böhm überzeugt Johannes kühn als besser
deutscher auf Rang 6
wichtiges Erfolgserlebnis für Hertha BSC
im ersten Sonntagsspiel der
Fußball-Bundesliga vier zu eins gegen
Borussia Mönchengladbach die Borussia
rutscht um einen Platz runter auf zehn
die härter um einen hoch auf 16 und noch
einmal Wintersport kompakt zuerst der
respektabel 10 Platz von Thomas Dresen
in der Abfahrt unter schwierigen
Bedingungen bei der alpinen WM in Kurve
Fähre glückwunsch von Thomas Dresen an
die neuen Abfahrt Weltmeister Marco
Odermatt aus der Schweiz der schnellste
vor dem Norweger und dem Kanal der
Alexander Thomas Dreesen als Zehnter
bester Deutscher verpasst das Podest um
2600 beim Triumph des Schweizer Odermatt
die dreimalige rodel-weltmeisterin Julia
taubitz macht den Erfolg des Wochenendes
in Winterberg komplett vier deutsche
Siege in vier Einzelrennen dazu
Bahnrekord in Innsbruck von Laura Nolte
im Zweierbob Platz 1 und Gesamtweltcup
genau wie Francesco Friedrich im
Viererbob
nach dem ersten Saison sie gestern
Andreas Willinger auch heute in stark
einer besser der Norweger Krane rückt
nicht zu bezwingen Wellinger auf Rang
zwei Tritte in leckt lässt sich Stefan
Kraft
tolles Wetter und alpin plus Biathlon WM
wieder am Dienstag hier bei uns dann
vielen Dank Christine wir haben jetzt
noch die Wetteraussichten für Sie im
Westen und am Alpenrand länger sonnig
sonst nur langsamer Auflösung von Nebel
und Hochnebel in der Nordosthälfte und
in einigen Fluss der Land den ganzen Tag
über trüb 5 bis 12 Grad
vielen Dank das war's von uns um 21:45
Uhr meldet sich Christian Sievers mit
dem heute journal im Fokus natürlich
auch die Berlin Wahl mit der ist jetzt
hier auch weitergeht wir geben wieder
live ab zu Bettina Schausten nach Berlin